الكويت الى اين تساؤل مستمر بعد قرار
المحكمه الدستوريه الصادم ببطلان مجلس
الامه المنتخب في العام الماضي 2022 وعوده
مرزوق الغانم لرئاسه المجلس مجددا الغانم
دعى في مؤتمر عقده بمقر المجلس بالامثله
اقرار قانون المفوضيه العليا للانتخابات
مؤكدا ان النوابه
ومؤازرتهم للحكومه مرتبط
بصدقها في وعودها عبر برنامجها الشامل في
وقت لا تزال فيه الحكومه حكومه تسير اعمل
رئيس مجلس الامه العائد الى منصبه مرزوق
الغانم قال ان الكويت لا تزال في ذات
الدوامه والحلقه المفرغه وسط حاله احباط
يعيشها البعض مع تغير المجالس والحكومات
على حد قوله
لا يخفى على احد حاله الاحباط لذاك قطاع
كبير من ابناء الشعب الكويتي اذ تغيرت
المجلس وتغيرت الحكومات ولا نزال في نفس
الدوامه والحلقه المفرزه وهذا يدفعني الى
التاكيد على نقطه مفصليه وهي ان المساله
ليست مجلس 20 او 22 وليس مرزوق الغانم او
السيد احمد السعدون الموضوع ليس شيخان
الفاضلان صباح الخالد او احمد النواف
القضيه اكبر من تلك الثنائيات المظلله
والمتخيله والقاصره اذ هي قضيه خطاب
سياسيه تمتع بالوعي والبصيره وممارسه
ناضجه قوامها الموضوعات والملفات لا
الاشخاص والاسماء وهما عمران يستهدفان
شيئا واحدا وهو تعزيز شعور المواطنه في
نفوس الناس واعاده ايمانهم في بلدهم
ومستقبله وهذا لن يتاتى الا ببرنامج عمل
وطني يتحقق اجماع الامه عليه وفق جدول
زمني محدد ودقيق وصادم يعيد ثقه المواطن
بمؤسساته وهنا اؤكد نيابه عن اغلبيه اعضاء
مجلس الامه انه متى ما صدقت الحكومه في
وعودها ابر برنامجها الشامل فنحن على
استعداد كامل لتقديم كل الدعم والمؤازره
لها لتحقيق الغايات الوطنيه المرجوه
من الكويتي انضم الينا الصحفي محمد السبتي
السيد محمد حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
كل سنه وانت طيب بمناسبه شهر رمضان
المبارك
خليني ابدا معك بالرسائل التي اراد مرزوق
الغانم
توجيهها في خطاب الامس ولمن كانت هذه
الرسائل موجه
حقيقه في ظن انه لا رسائل موجهه هو كلام
لا يعدو ان يكون تنظير شبعنا منه سماعا
منذ فتره طويله هذا الكلام غير قابل
للتطبيق عندما نتكلم عن وعي سياسي كيف
نحصل على هذا الوعي السياسي هل هناك دواء
يشربه المجتمع مثلا فينتج عنه وعيا سياسيا
تكلم السيد مرزوق الغانم عن ممارسه سياسيه
مسؤوله كيف نحصل على هذه الممارسه
السياسيه المسؤوله الكل ينشد تلك الاهداف
ولا احد منا يستطيع
الوصول الى تلك الاهداف لانها اقرب الى
الاماني منها الى الاهداف التي يمكن
تحقيقها وفق المعطيات هذا شعبنا وتلك
كتلًا وسياسيه وهذا طبيعه تفكيرينا
وعقولنا في ممارسه هذه العمليه الانتخابيه
وهذه نتائجها
التنظير لا يعني شيئا لذلك اليوم الخلاف
المعضله
الماساه التي تعيشه الكويت سياسيا بين
الحكومه والمجلس بين المجلس والمجلس هناك
خلاف وخلاف شديد
ويعني انسداد للافق بين المجلس ذاته بين
كتل وكتل الخلاف لم يكن حكوميا مع المجلس
بل كان مع المجلس مع المجلس ما هي الحلول
لهذه الازمه ولهذه الخلافات الجواب لا
حلول لا تطرحوا حلول ما طرحه السيد رئيس
مجلس الامه لا يعني شيئا على الناحيه
العمليه حتى العمليه السياسيه عنها مساله
انتخابات العوده الى
المواطن الكويتي
القرارات المفوضيه العليا للانتخابات نظام
لا يمكن ان تتخذ كطريق للمعالجه
يعني لنفرض مثلا ما طرحه السيد مرزوق
الغانم بضروره انشاء المفوضيه العليا
للانتخابات لماذا اليوم لما حل مجلس الامه
لم يكن بسبب ماخذ وشبهات يعني حامت حول
العمليه الانتخابيه تم حل مجلس الامه
لوجود خلل في مرسوم الحل لا في وجود خلل
اصابع العمليه الانتخابيه لم يكن يوما من
الايام حلم مجلس الامه ثلاث مرات هذه مره
والمرتين السابقتين في ال2012 كل تلك
الحلول التي جاءت من المحكمه الدستوريه
بطلان عمليه الانتخاب لم تكن بسبب وجود
خلل في العمليه الانتخابيه بل بسبب وجود
خلل في المراسيم الاميريه التي تصدر من
الحكومه بحل مجلس الامه لذلك المفوضيه
الانتخابيه وان كانت مناداه حق لا ننكر
انها مناداه حق وانها ضروره لكنها لا تحل
مشكله لان
وجود الخلل او عدم وجود الخلل يحل ب 60
الف طريقه قد تكون واليوم يعني الجميع ان
من يقوم بزمام الامور بالاشراف على العمله
الانتخابيه هي السلطه القضائيه كذلك الا
ان مطرحه السيد مرزوق الغانم بالاشاره الى
ضروره الاستعجال باقرار قانون المفوضيه
الانتخابيه كانه يشير الى ان الانتخابات
التي مضت يعني كان فيها خللا كبيرا وان لم
يقر احدا لم تقر الاحكام القضائيه بوجود
مثل هذا الخلل بل ولم تناقشه اصلا لان كان
الخلل بوجود تلك المراسيم الاميريه التي
صدرتها الحكومه بعلم مجلس الامه لذلك قلت
في البدايه ان هذا كلام لا يعدو ان يكون
تمظيرا سياسيا
لا ناتجه من ورائه في حل تلك الازمه
والمعضله والدوامه التي اشار اليها رئيس
مجلس الامه يعيش المجتمع منذ سنوات وتلك
وهذا التنظير لا يحلها ابدا افق المشكله
الان الى اين يتجه في ظل حاله الاحتراب
الصراع مع النواب مواقفهم يعني اكثر من
نائب كانوا انتقدوا ما قاله الغانم مثل
الدكتور عبد العزيز الصقعبي على سبيل
المثال قال بان الغانم لا يبحث عن
انتخابات مزينه نزيهه ويبحث عن شراء الوقت
فقط لاحياء مجلس منتهي شعبيا تصريحات ايضا
جاءت على لسان عبد الكريم الكندري كذلك
عبيد الوسمي الذي قال ان كان هناك من زور
فلماذا فلماذا تم التزوير ويجب ان نعرف من
هو ولمصلحه من ما رايك في مثل هذا الكلام
كل كل تلك الاطروحات لا تعني الا يعني
[موسيقى]
لتنشيط وممارسه اهداف شخصيه عند هؤلاء
الكتل السياسيه ليس الا تلك الاطروحات لا
يمكن بحال ان تحل تلك الازمه السياسيه
التي نعانيها انت على فرض جدلا اننا
اجرينا انتخابات مبكره بالغد مثلا ثم جاء
مجلس امه بانتخابات لا يعني ليس فيها
شائبه هل يتوقع احد في الكويت هناك مليون
و400 الف مواطن كويتي لا احد من هؤلاء
المليون الى 400 الف يتوقع ان ينتج من تلك
الانتخابات ناتج ايجابي في العمليه
السياسيه مارسناها من قبل نحن نجرب الذي
جربناه المشكله ليس في انتخابات مبكره
المشكله ليست في مخرجات انتخابات المشكله
ليست في شخوص من يعين يعني رئيسا للوزراء
او او شخوص النواب هذه هذا يعني هروب من
كل الكتل السياسيه لمواجهه حقيقه المشكله
التي يعانيها المجتمع وهي باختصار هي هذا
النظام الذي النظام الانتخابي الذي
فشل له دون ان المسلمين في الكويت
يعني سالتك هذا السؤال مرارا وتكرارا يعني
خلال
الايام والسنوات القليله الماضيه في حل
ولا لا في الكويت من الاخر
الحل واقعيا يعني نترك تلك الممارسات
عندما يجروا الناس للاسف هنا لا لا واقعين
ليس هناك حل لان الكل اقولها اقولها
وبصراحه الكل يخجل من الاعتراف بفشل
النظام الانتخابي الكل يعتقد ان من المعيب
اليوم هناك حاله في الكويت لا ينبغي لمثقف
ولا لمحامي ولا لكاتب صحفي ان يفكر فقط
التفكير في فشل هذا النظام الانتخابي
يعتبروه الناس هنا معيبا لان هناك سطوه
على هذه المناداه اما ان نمارس تلك
العمليه الانتخابيه والا فمن ينادي بغير
ذلك هو دكتاتوري وذنب للسلطه من مسميات
هناك سطوه فكريه من مثل هذه الاطروحات
لذلك يخجل الكثير من الناس ونعاب يعاب
امثالنا في كل مكان في كل منتدى على ما
نقوله من اعترافنا بفشل هذا النظام
الانتخابي